mientras estaba haciendo mi pequeño
análisis para darme cuenta si el plan
básico o el plan de prueba es el que más
me conviene e hicimos un análisis para
determinar el número de sesiones donde
el costo del plan de prueba es igual al
costo del plan básico hice estos
cálculos donde obtuve que eran cinco
sesiones no me di cuenta pero el
encargado del estudio de super yoga me
estaba viendo y me dijo bien sal eso
está muy bien lo que hiciste maravilloso
según entiendo hay un número de sesiones
donde 12s
es exactamente igual a 20 más 8 s donde
obtenemos exactamente el mismo costo
donde 20 más 8 por s es igual a 12 por s
otra manera de ver esto es que la sé que
obtienes con 20 más 8 ese coincide con
la ce que obtienes con 12 s las
igualamos encontramos ese para
posteriormente encontrar el costo pero
el encargado me dice yo tengo otra
manera de hacerlo y quiero ver si
obtenemos la misma respuesta
así es que según su manera de verlo me
dice fíjate en esto sabemos que el costo
del plan básico
sabemos que el costo del plan básico
es igual
20 dólares 20 dólares por sesión
bueno no de hecho son 20 dólares de
adelanto que se tienen que dar más más 8
dólares por cada sesión más 8 ese es lo
que sabemos y lo que queremos averiguar
es cuál es el número de sesiones donde
obtenemos el mismo costo tomando el plan
básico o tomando el plan de prueba y me
dijo tengo una idea para transformar
esta ecuación en una ecuación de una
sola variable actualmente es una
ecuación que nos da el costo dependiendo
del número de sesiones pero él tenía o
por lo menos pensaba que tenía una
manera para eliminar la cee de la
ecuación me dijo lo que voy a hacer es
restar la cee del lado izquierdo me dijo
entonces que simplemente simplemente iba
a restarle se del lado izquierdo a lo
cual replique esperaste en un momento no
puede restarse no puedes hacer algo que
sólo afecte un lado de la ecuación pues
se perdería la igualdad y me dijo no no
no no te preocupes la ecuación no se va
a alterar pues voy a hacer lo mismo del
lado derecho de la ecuación
y entonces yo le dije eso no tiene
ningún caso pues ahora va a aparecer la
cee del lado derecho de la ecuación vas
a terminar con 20 + 8 s menos c así es
que no vas a deshacerte de la ce aún vas
a tener dos incógnitas y mi hijo no no
no sal no has entendido voy a restarse
del lado izquierdo pero sabemos que
estamos buscando una s de tal manera que
12 s nos da el mismo costo c este costo
ya sea que use el plan básico o use el
plan de prueba va a ser exactamente el
mismo
así es que cualquiera que sea el costo
que obtenga ya sea por el plan básico o
por el plan de prueba voy a restar ese
costo del lado izquierdo de tal manera
que se cancele enlaces mientras que del
lado derecho voy a restar el costo de 12
s así es que lo que hizo fue prestarse
del lado izquierdo cancelando así las es
y del lado derecho restó 12 s 12 s así
es que me pregunto es esto que hizo algo
válido básicamente
está restando esta ecuación de esta
ecuación está restando se del lado
izquierdo mientras que del lado derecho
está restando 12 ese es esto correcto
pensemos en esto sabemos que si tenemos
una ecuación y sumamos o restamos algo
del lado izquierdo tenemos que hacer
exactamente lo mismo del lado derecho lo
que le está haciendo es considerar que
sin importar qué plan tomamos existe un
número de sesiones donde obtenemos el
mismo costo así es que restamos ese
costo del lado izquierdo y ese costo
tiene que ser igual a 12s esto es lo que
queremos que se cumpla sabemos que estas
dos ecuaciones tienen que ser verdad en
este punto de coincidencia me dijo mira
si estas dos son iguales entonces restar
12 s de un lado es totalmente
equivalente a restarse del otro lado así
es que de hecho este es una operación
válida está restando lo mismo está
restando sea aquí y está restando 12 s
aquí sabemos que es lo mismo pues
estamos poniendo
esta restricción sabemos que se es igual
queremos que se cumpla al mismo tiempo
que sea igual a 20 más 8 s y que se sea
igual a 12 s cómo se tiene que ser igual
a 12 s podemos restar se de un lado y 12
s
del otro lado veamos a dónde nos lleva
esto si restamos se de un lado y
restamos 12 s del otro lado
desarrollamos entonces estas operaciones
del lado izquierdo que obtenemos c y
menos se cancelan
6 - se nos da 0 estos dos términos se
cancelan y acabamos con 0 del lado
izquierdo del lado derecho que obtenemos
20 queda como 20 y 8 de algo menos 12 de
algo 8 s menos 12 s es igual a menos 4 s
nos queda entonces 20 menos 4 s y
observemos algo interesante ahora tengo
una sola ecuación con una sola incógnita
s debemos entonces
dejad es ecuación la s y como lo hacemos
bien necesitamos dejar la variable de un
lado y yo lo voy a hacer del lado
izquierdo como bien sabes hay muchísimas
maneras de despejar una variable que
puede hacer entonces para tener las
heces del lado izquierdo y eliminarlas
del lado derecho así es que para
eliminar las heces del lado derecho
si estoy restando 4s aquí necesito sumar
entonces 4 s sumamos 4 s y de nueva
cuenta no puedo hacer esto nada más del
lado derecho pues perderíamos la
igualdad así es que tengo que hacerlo
también del lado izquierdo y que
obtenemos ahora
bien obtenemos 04 s del lado izquierdo
es 4 s y del lado derecho obtenemos
menos 4 s y 4 s se cancelan estos
términos se cancelan y nos queda tan
solo 20 la ecuación es ahora 4 s igual a
ahora para despejar s dividimos entonces
4 s entre 4 cuando tenemos 4 de algo
dividido entre 4 nos queda ese algo así
es que en el lado izquierdo hemos
despejado ese de nueva cuenta para no
afectar la ecuación también tenemos que
dividir entre 4 del lado derecho nos
resulta entonces que ese es igual a 20
entre 4 o s es igual a cinco sesiones
que es exactamente la respuesta que
habíamos obtenido antes y podemos
regresar entonces a cualquier de los
planes y ver que en ambos casos el costo
mensual va a ser 60 dólares lo curioso
del caso es que tanto el dependiente del
estudio superior como yo llegamos a la
misma respuesta por distintos métodos y
debido a que lo que ambos hicimos fue
lógicamente consistente y
es lo maravilloso del álgebra obtuvimos
la misma conclusión mientras sigamos
procedimientos que tengan consistencia
lógica siempre llegaremos a la respuesta
exacta